thank you I carry for coming up with an
idea and inviting me thanks to chamois
and to the nasal awful says to the
economics department and to the
university of Colombia it's nice to be
here there are a lot of old friends in
the audience um basically this is this
like a really weird project because it
actually started while I was started
while i was working on all these
different things i'm not an economist
and it actually started because I'm such
a bad accountant I was actually I can't
tell the whole circuit it's too
humiliating but I found myself in deep
financial trouble um while studying
jean-baptiste Colbert on because I was
such a poor accountant and I was
studying Colbert doing amazing
accounting trying to talk about briefly
I was like what and I was like how can
this be happening you know I mean how
can someone goes to you know these gets
a major PhD in the modern age you know
really nothing about this economists do
don't realize how little people do know
about this and I became sort of more
fascinated by this odd sort of
disconnect in modern education with
accounting and then um so a couple
things happen um essentially one thing
that sort of struck me well I'll just
sort of tell the story I was on studying
a Louis the fourteenth and colbert's
relationship and how Colbert made an
information system and and partly for
himself but also for Louie the 14th
unless it was gonna skip ahead here and
show you this and um so this basically I
was stunned to find that in Colbert's
own hand he had actually copied out long
passages from
the YouTube first printed manual and
accounting my pacioli for Louis the
fourteenth which will be the 14th of red
he wrote about to his mother he wrote
about how much you love being able to do
accounting this is these are
unbelievable letters were promised no
one cares about because they're about
about accounting then um Colbert did
something much more extraordinary he
went to UM shahi studio and johnny was
Nicosia he was responsible for bringing
the Guildhall new journey which in the
17th century is one of them perhaps the
most beautiful work of calligraphy of
the 17th century um and Colbert had
actually helped him produces there's an
amazing reporter of Colbert in this book
and he had a Johnny studio made for Ruby
the 14 these golden notebooks they're
bound in mah jongg that they had google
gold clasps and ban the video technical
doesn't like you to ever see them and
the reason was that they know that
they're there and i asked to take the
pictures i said yeah but nobody else
does and that they didn't care and so i
have to threaten i'm enes them i know
they let me but it was a long stressful
you know kind of POD fell between and
whatever but i got the pictures and I
was stunned by these books for 20 years
Louis the fourteenth keeps these basic
account books in his pocket they are
basically income and expenditure um and
then they actually have his capital
holdings which I also know that he knew
enough about land and what things were
worth to understand these capital hold
in the back of each book for 20 years
Luther 14 holds these in his pocket um
and that's already amazing because Kings
didn't do that I'm writing a book about
this now there's a whole reason that
Kings don't look at account books Philip
the second brag that he looked at every
piece of information on earth
but he didn't touch the comic books
there was the Spanish did accounting
everywhere but not Philip the second all
information interested in except
accounting this was not a thing that was
seen as a good thing to do accounting
was associated at least for high
aristocrats as a kind of lower
mercantile thing so for Louie the 14 to
take a joy in this and to do it for 20
years seemed to me to be sort of a grand
moment in the history of statecraft and
there was enough evidence to show this
was the case this happened it was it was
a fairly big deal but what was even more
interesting to me and this sort of
coincided with my own personal
incompetents lack of knowledge
disconnect from an accounting was that
Louis the fourteenth when Colbert dies
he ends the books he doesn't just end
them he ends the actual system by which
he could get good accounts and he breaks
up the Ministry of Finance from the
Ministry of the Navy and actually kind
of breaks it up from other things too
like the Royal Library which is really
necessary believe it or not for
accounting because so many legal texts
are going in and out of it um so Louisa
14th essentially makes or stops reforms
or breaks up institutional frameworks
which would allow him to actually
understand his account well or at least
anybody else to understand another
reason was really you know in the in the
years leading up to Colbert's death
death in 1683 the financial news just
kept getting worse and Louie the 14th
just didn't like it um and this by the
way is no small deal this is a great
human trade than we like to drop the
account books when they start getting
bad or perhaps change them around um so
I was sort of stunned by this and I put
it
I I said this is really interesting and
I want to understand more about just
because this King the shrimp you know
divided right monarch who secretly
writes letters to his mom about how he
loves accounting okay so this is not how
we see Louis the fourteenth and his
youth you know having love affairs in
rivers cover me rose petals you know as
Jamal like to sort of a talent no he was
sitting learning this account stuff um
we also know who the 14th love the
so-called much injured though the
mention wha the business be king yeah
well then why did he destroy his system
so there are all these sort of questions
in here which really really interested
me I was like you know what I think
there's a project in here and so I sort
of started digging now just one sort of
note then just a sort of side note as
this sort of project was happening the
financial crisis happened um lots of
financial crises have happened all over
the place but and you'll understand why
this interesting me after this paper on
one of the things that stunned me the
most as I was studying um basically the
interest in numbers and government and
the representation of good government by
numbers was the fact that our in our own
political discourse numbers had taken on
a very strange on role and when
America's credit rating was down rated
by the SP two hours later some assistant
guy in the Treasury Department said hey
there's a two trillion dollar error and
I was like all right this is what I'm
studying and so I went and so I ran to
the Treasury Department website and this
is what they gave okay this is it
besides a few explanations then I said
this is going to be great there's going
to be this 18th century-style debate
about
how some people calculate the deficit or
spending and how some people do it
differently and so I went to the wall
street journal i went to bloomberg just
some vague stuff five percent difference
you know how much revenue is going to
come in it was incredibly vague and I
was like wait a minute we're literally
United States of America is getting
downgraded its credit rating we're
having a debate about a two trillion
dollar error there are no numbers
floating around their own calculations
and and the weirdest thing is no one's
asking for it because that I'm a
cultural and intellectual historic so I
was like wow no one is asking for them
is that we don't we all understood what
happened is that what it was do we care
that there is a 2 trillion dollar area
doesn't this seem like something of
staggering enormity that would be a
central thing in political discourse and
what I found was it wasn't I was like
wow you know this is really interesting
there is a problem there's a disconnect
between accounting and politics there's
an odd relationship between a and this
book sort of sort of takes for from this
funny relationship and so what I want to
show you today is this kind of key
moment in the relationship between
politics publicity and we could call
them the numbers of accounting we could
call them calculation we could call it
computing or we could call it the air
Sox numbers just numbers in general and
what they represent politically so
essentially what happens is I was like
look you know we know we get to a point
we know we get to a point where in
governments people start becoming judged
as you know leaders by their management
of spending deficits and finance when
does a good politician or a good leader
become a good man
public finance at public finance um and
there are examples but I was more
interested not only in you know when of
good leaders associated not with prowess
and virtue and and and representing a
nation in a certain way or winning a war
but in this relationship with numbers
and leadership I was also interested
just in the idea when did this language
come about that we're going to start
talking about the state and its health
in numbers whether we understand them or
not the state won't be represented
necessarily as a diagnostic state or as
a state you know connected to a king or
connected to an ideal or in the 20th
century to an ideology but also just
this idea this is kind of very almost
you know possibly scary idea of a state
represented by numbers on we know that
there's the birth of statistics in the
18th century but again I wanted to know
when people start talking about a
certain kind or showing numbers as
political virtue so I said well
obviously it doesn't happen in France so
I looked everywhere else and I go back
to italy and i had dig deep into Dutch
history and it was impossible i spent a
year not being able to really master
17th century Dutch and despite mother's
partner I still failed at it you know I
know what kind of thing is I was like
luckily they didn't know about that well
so I
I looked at the rise of political
economy and the first authors of
political economy I looked at the
authors of political arithmetic and
statistic I studied the work of will
derringer in the audience here we're
doing one of the best phd's I've ever
seen on these questions in England at
the beginning of the 18th century and
he's going to be here in the Society of
fellows now and you guys should just
hire because you're not going to get
work better than that on the open market
right now um so and I found in his work
and we've discussed it that the English
really discussed numbers politically
this incredibly sophisticated way at the
beginning of the 18th century but
there's no echo of it it doesn't hold
okay so you have incredible figures like
Peter de la kluwer in Holland writing
perhaps one of the most moving and
forgotten about works of Republican
theory uh where he where he correlates a
good Republic's with basically good
accounting um there are other works in
the late 17th early 18th century which
sort of thing look this is it this is
going to be the beginning of this and
each time one sort of startled me was
these beginnings these books like Peter
glencore's work and then your guys is in
cruickshank and I'm just saying they're
not that well-known they should be in
the history of Finance and government
those guys are innovators okay but as it
again a sort of historian of politics
and culture I was like
amazing I'm studying all of Europe I'm
not finding is it must have started
somewhere and so of course I just went
back to Paris to drink because i
couldn't find i was looking for us like
you know another project bites the dust
and i went to the library and um and I
started looking into the 18th century in
France and I knew that there were
numbers out there and I was like you
know maybe they start here and I knew
about Jacques necker's called home you
and I had read about it and actually
some of the best work about it has never
been published it's actually in Bob
Tartans PhD which is I just got
digitized at Harvard Bob goes some way
with it but it was this was interesting
and so what happened is I started
digging into Necker and I started
finding this was I believe this sort of
major major moment where a little
discourse and the numbers of accounting
become fused and become wildly popular
so it's not the first time but it's this
kind of incredible moment where
government and good government quite
literally those words it's not the first
time they are used together but if he
becomes public it spreads across Europe
and then what I'm going to try and show
you today is it becomes a movement a
movement so extreme within the French
government that a tradition and
institutional tradition is formed that
becomes so strong that even the English
for once look to France and actually
send people to Frances on tie the end to
say wow how did you guys do this and one
of the reasons French public financial
management and the vision this modern
vision of the state come from a
of political publicity and so that's
what I want to talk about today um now
what's amazing is is the cult holder by
Necker 1781 the cold for new oh wah the
accounts rendered to the k not to the
public to the king is one um is an
amazing as an amazing work now
essentially what i wanted to also do is
I wanted to try and understand this sort
of long history of the French
relationship to numbers and I found
something even more even through design
and this is something we don't
necessarily usually talk about is deep
within the French government for a
hundred years there had been an argument
about whether to define the state
through the numbers of accounting nobody
knows about this because these are
internal memos there are internal memos
which are hundreds of pages long they
often include long a double entry
account which explained the only way to
do good government is through this kind
of accounting which is what your guys
kind of do in England in the same period
around 17 16 in 1716 in France the these
financier is called the paki brothers
basically make this internal argument um
and essentially a the French crown
ministers agree that these guys will
come in and do these accounting reforms
and so they start and one of these in
amazing I'm actually not reading the
paper now it's a little out of order but
I'll get back to their there is neck or
presenting the accounts to the king
there is being called Michelle that you
sit and I'll get back to this but the
paki brothers doing all these internal
memoirs and again I have them digitized
and printed them there's stacks like
this and it actually took me months to
really because it was just brutally
morning for an intellectual historian to
read through these things they had to do
it they have classical and medieval
history because its financial history
but the end of it they really just get
to the numbers and they do this
accounting miraculously but before John
law and after John law they get laws
made that essentially every member of
the financial class has to learn how to
do double entry bookkeeping they kept is
made into a law in 1716 and then 1723
they come in before John law and right
after John law and the Mississippi Pablo
essentially they get these laws made
which were printed some of them posted
on walls okay um models to make
registers and journals and basically and
it's it and how to do it in double entry
and they explain how to do it each time
law forts them first and then everybody
else sports the maquette in 1723 these
laws never really take effect but
they're published they're completely
forgotten by economic historians only
one accounting historian in France has
ever published on this and yet within
the government there's a mass of work on
this and there are published laws on it
these things never took hold
when we get to the physiocrats in France
credited by many as the early inventors
of economic thought they will produce
her go by the way tried to do a lot of
these same accounting reforms and I'll
mention that again and you know as a
kind of basis of the work of Adam Smith
they like to throw around through an
economic tableau and they but they
didn't like these numbers in fact those
numbers were to associated with people
who are connected to colbert and so you
had a few code baptiste a guy named full
Binet was an amazing guy whose work
looks a lot like cruickshanks because he
talks about the mortise Minh of debt and
other things he produces a long work on
accounting in the state but he says I
have to do this from the exterior I
can't get these numbers so he produces
this really remarkable work it's only
published twice and it does not have a
huge echo and so I was it Wow so the
cult holder which I'm about to describe
to you like this this thing sort of
comes out of an odd vacuum in France and
I became more and more interested by
um and so essentially i went back to
nectar and i tried to understand this
context in which um Necker does
something that really really no one had
ever done before um Necker comes in to
government as I think many people know
at the height of the American War of
Independence it's the same moment that
both the English and French are having
financial crises to pay for this war and
the French brave nectar in due to his
popularity and due to his relationship
with Geneva and other bankers on to
secure loans I was actually recently in
Lausanne with a whole bunch of Swiss
people and um it's really interesting
because they were talking about these
moments when parts of Switzerland own
France and England there's just these
sort of amazing moment to bring in this
was financier makes an enormous amount
of sense um not only that necker um was
his wife had very well known salon it
was before his daughter that a misdial
came into her own he was well seen among
pillows off he was a popular figure
amongst many um and essentially he's
brought in in the 1780s to do the
reforms exact almost exactly to some
extent that the paki brothers and turgot
had failed to do which is to try and get
the financial to keep double entry books
so they could actually figure out tax
receipts and just to figure out how much
money
he hath was spending simple stuff but
not a few nobody uses double entry it's
not very simple um so what he does is
try to install a centralized system of
tax collection and auditing um and this
threatens everyone who is involved with
finance because everyone has a hand in
this pot on the parliament has a hand in
this pot because they have to they get
cuts from the finance ears and they have
to register certain things um hi Nobles
have an interest in the accounts not
being good because everyone's worried
about getting taxed and so no one wants
clear accounting done and imported I'm
kind of exaggerating there are other
Nobles that do want it but really at the
end of the day there's a great movement
against against these reforms was
threatened so many entrenched financial
interests um he tries to streamline the
tax and postal farms and cuts the number
of venal administrators to save the
crown enormous raw revenues lost to
feudal office holders and he does
eliminate three-quarters of the 48 tax
collectors because he's so into 12
heavily audited officers um and so this
centralizes state accounting um and he
even threatens just to get rid of much
of the financial class of the ulsio
regime um now as he's trying to do this
as is the great French tradition
especially at this time he starts
getting attacked in the pen
press on and this goes on for a little
while and Necker can hold out and
essentially um this movement of this
movement of pamphlets will be called the
neck home and the neck Romania around a
becker what happens is slowly he starts
getting dragged through the mud he sort
of stays you know on Olympus for a while
but in 1781 sorry I hope today 1781
libelous anonymous pamphlet stands out
and it is by this guy named Jacques
metric Isaiah and Isaiah writes
something called the anonymous letter
for Mitchell chill go to Monsieur Necker
which is filled with lots of financial
information it's a narrative of nectars
bad administration but it has numbers
and it has bits and pieces of accounts
and it doesn't more so it has numbers
and it looks really plausible looks like
the person it looks like it was a leak
okay it looks like it came from within
the government the government isn't
doesn't produce financial numbers so
this has quite an effect but he goes
further and he attacks and edgar is a
Swiss banker bent on draining money from
the state he says that um he has taken
people's fortunes away and has himself
as a huge huge fortune and he names
numbers and then he says you know this
is a citizen of Geneva who knows better
than I and everyone else the ABCs of the
business of keeping like um of
accounting and keeping registers he says
he has a SPOC to apotheke and that this
really is nothing more than the little
calculation of banks and money so he
throw it's a brilliant
he throws numbers at him and then says
but all this guy cares about are these
little calculations so it's a double
move and this hurts a Necker um oceak
himself called the pamphlet of devilish
success madam to default said that six
thousand copies appear immediately went
throughout the court necker was hit and
he had to react even more than that Oh
Chanel publishes this is strong a
tableau combative of the laws passed by
John law and by Necker this is after
everything and what it says these are
the same laws he's going to bring us to
financial ruin people should be
panicking about this guy so this is a
real attack on Necker an echo basically
has to respond he's got to do something
he couldn't keep his hands clean um an
echo is really his a brilliant guy me
his writings might not be fantastically
brilliant but he understood the world of
parisian actually more than that of
european information he understood
credit he understood a lot of things and
he came up with this brilliant move to
publish the cult hole dude
what um in fact this was the kind of
gesture that Beltran the foreign
minister had worried that he would do
when he was appointed because this was
an enlightened guy and he did it without
a royal permission even though in it um
even though it was published and
essentially what he does is he claimed
to reveal the veritable accounts of the
government and he hoped that quote this
publicity would restore public
confidence in his administration by
shining light on the obscure writings
and the mystery of state of finance what
he does is he uses his old traditional
political language of task ilysm and by
the way a Machiavellian isn't a season
he even hasn't some of the cult under
big quotes by taxes on the front so
vales have been put up on over
government he's going to unveil them
with this called home dude um ah and
this will be a moral act he set of moral
prosperous happy and powerful government
um at the end of his calculations and
here it is two heroes his here's his
cold he comes up with this lesson
thought we can't see very well which is
a
his calculations revenues exceed
expenditures by 10 million two hundred
thousand leave ah and this shows the
power and the prosperity of not only the
sovereign by his subjects we literally
says this 10 million vive shows the
power of Louis the sixteenth um this had
an amazing success 60,000 copies pen
coupe the publisher of the various
encyclopdie printed 60,000 copies in a
week okay more than a hundred thousand
copies were sold in 1781 alone some were
translated across Europe my friends
sofas writer counts many of these
financial publications he thinks that
there are hundreds of thousands of
copies of the colonial running through
Europe it was a literal media phenomenon
and one of the things I know is that
they were red bike races and princes
like petrol Leopoldo of who was perhaps
in some ways the most successful
enlightening prints at his age actually
once his own identity Kong tub in
Florence a financial thing so it has a
huge huge echo um now to sort of move
forward he was immediately attacked and
Belgian actually says to Louie the 16
how could you let this happen we can't
let this go on he's attacking a reason
of state he's attacking the secret and
the mystery of monarchy itself monarchy
which was supposed to be the will of the
king is now being shown he literally
said your powers in these numbers this
is a bad thing um so there is a
realization um it takes a little while
for necker's
phos to pick this up um but basically by
1787 so years go by necker loses his
ministry and other ministers come in and
in 1787 the controller generals finances
of cologne finds himself in a position
in front of the Assembly of Notables
where he has to defend this massive
state deficit and he produces another
book a cult whole new against Necker in
which he comes up with loads of numbers
and basically says look this deficit
that I'm dealing with is neckers deficit
and Necker did not include 46 million
three hundred and twenty-nine thousand
pounds in his cult whole new and so
essentially a war of numbers goes on
between necro and Cologne and this is
when this really takes off because
interestingly at first nectars call tony
is taken kind of seriously the fact is
is that while some of the calculations
were good it really was missing this
jump a hidden 45 million leave up whole
Necker comes back with his own
calculations and one of the things he
says which is sort of terrifying look
look first of all there's no way to
really make these calculations because I
never could make my reforms so no one
did double entry bookkeeping so I
couldn't actually get the real numbers
not only that this is a tricky genre we
always have to be careful with numbers
mean more or less throw tries to
undermine the genre and then he says
look of course I didn't mention those
numbers those are the numbers that had
to do with war and war is extraordinary
that's real reason of State and I didn't
want to risk the state's reason of state
by doing this this only essentially sets
off a war over numbers and then
something happens um essentially in 17
ah in 1788 a number of leaks started
coming
the government of kind of basically
budget state budgets are leap down so
they actually have the year of income
and expenditure get leaked out by a guy
named Matt don't let accrual um and he
says Matt somewhere like closest look
this has never happened not only that we
didn't even know how to print these
things it's all manuscript all we have
to do this now we have to unveil all
these mysteries because everyone just
goes by rumors and unjust approaches
happening and we can have a rational
argument unless the real numbers are out
there um and so essentially by 1789 a
flurry of coal news come out and then
even more a number of works equating
good government with accounting and
double entry accounting come out the new
OC to a bid the embedded deep which i
think is I'm going to argue the cruel
encyclopedia of the 18th century um
which not that many people reference but
it's the second most eq ability that
comes out which is never finished
include loses a million leaves were
doing it it basically has a whole three
volumes on finance and commerce and it
takes up accounting and these accounting
reforms and really starts talking about
the state in this new way rather than
Commerce and finances these kind of
grand philosophical things they become
these kind of very technical things
deeply linked to accounting and the use
of double entry um now necker I think as
many people know is dismissed on the
11th of jock July 1789 this and the fear
that troops are being masked around
Paris leads to people crowding around
the besties several days later so Necker
and his clarity are very important
things
after the fall of the bestie two days
later neckers call back to his office
and he publishes more cold holder but as
the revolution picks up steam and as the
National Assembly is born necker sort of
fades from view however cold whole news
don't and they remain a central genre of
political language and the idea that
good government is linked to good
accounting becomes enshrined in all
revolutionary constitutions the
constitution of 1791 stipulates the
detailed accounts of the expenditures of
ministerial departments signed and
certified by the ministers or general
managers should be rendered public by
being printed at the beginning of the
sessions of every legislature the same
shall apply to statements of receipts
from diverse taxes from all public
revenues ie every thing that happens in
government has to be measured by
accounting and then published in a cult
all-new princess in a quilt will do so
the cult wonder becomes essentially a
constitutional which is really quite
extraordinary by 1793 um it comes back
in it comes back in and the convulsion
puts together a commission on accounting
but it has a problem and this is a
problem with the Dutch in the English
and the Florentines don't have is
accounting in France is still done in
internal family companies that aren't
there are accounting firms but you don't
have people floating around numbers of
them who are highly trained double entry
accounting while in England there are
thousand by the end of the 18th century
there are a thousand writing schools for
commoners and gentlemen alike um so
francesa sort of grave disadvantage and
so the commission writes about this and
the commission on
how things look we're going to get these
commissars could come esata wrong word
sorry um sorry this is these are them
this is the fight between a turbo and
neck are all done fighting with numbers
and here are some of the amazing called
home do and works that come afterwards
um but this commission that comes out
that might have actually been in that
just press the button so it's going to
change sorry I just there's a there's a
plethora of works on so here is the
project of organizing the Bureau of
continuity and what's beautiful at is at
the end they produce their account of
how much it cost 499 thousand and one
leave and they say it's really expensive
because we have to Train everybody from
scratch and to train credible double
entry auditors really new leaks sip it
is expensive but it's beautiful because
as a pro according to the constitution
now every act that you do have to be
accounted for um and so this this
happens and literally we get this
massive we get this massive explosion of
of cult whole news everywhere in
government um seduced during the terror
would call paperwork demonic and a
hinderence to revolutionary government
um and we we know that that's true and
however a Republican accountability
remains though and after the terror it
comes back in force and they're amazing
I don't have time to talk about this but
there are amazing political battles in
which people attack for example the
ministry of the arm mr. of the Army's
the general Shia who's actually trying
to reform accounting within the army the
people who is going after a attack him
with a come home do which is really
deadly because they published this thing
it says called home do of general shanna
and basically his corrupt administration
and Shia has to produce a whole bunch of
cofilin doozy in response and he
eventually goes down and a number of
people for example Hamed who is a
minister of finance he's attacked as
well and in order to defend himself he
too produces his own cult whole new so
this goes on this idea of the cult
holder as political language but there's
something even sort of deeper that
happens within the government and this
was actually in some ways thought it was
part of this project is that um so again
it just keeps going there just you can
just dig into into these works which by
the way in many cases when you go into
the collections in France and in America
of revolutionary doctorates they've
never been opened because they all say
accounting and
and no nobody cares it just say called
whole new culture luckily at the
University of Pennsylvania they have the
McClure collection and at the University
of Pennsylvania um I'm friends with the
people in the rare book room and I think
it was last Christmas I got drunk with
them at the Christmas party and um and I
was like I'm doing this project and I
can figure it out it's kind of one of
these conversation I'm actually
simulating that the conversation hasn't
won and they were like wanting to come
back into the stack so I was like RI
let's go so we go back into the stacks
and there's just this huge because they
have this giant collection of
revolutionary enhance let's it's a
beautiful clutch and luckily there's
this whole shelf that says speedos and
on that shelf or several shells but one
of the shelves just say called holder
which is literally a shelf of Calder's
half of the shelf of culinary our
individual holy by deputies at any agent
of this state there are hundreds of them
these are the ones just collected by
this guy McClure's agent during the
Revolution he was the Philadelphia who
had been in Paris and said this
revolution is important I made a lot of
money i'm going to get as much
information on as I can hundreds of
these things every single person that
goes on resumes for the government has
to produce basically these one two three
page called whole news where they are
essentially um they kind of confess it's
like a miniature confession of what they
do and on one occasion the deputy unveil
from the
department of love and men explains how
he took 9999 in the evil from the
Treasury spent 1262 on transport 16,000
958 on food and lodging for 25 days and
617 for aid to the poor through such
knowledge um this cost him 14 thousand
eight hundred and twenty-five leave alot
more than he had taken therefore he
deposited his receipts to the aspect dr.
Conte he returned his coach and his cow
to the national depot and he's waiting
for his to be reimbursed but nonetheless
this is published it's published by the
ambiguity of the astronaut so hundreds
of these things come out so essentially
every agent of the government is forced
to think about their acts in these kind
of very simplistic and basic terms of
accounting and this kind of confession
Republican confession of accounting and
at the higher scale all the ministers
have to reproduce these very detailed
cult all nude on s your walk actually
has told me that a lot of these cult
whole news they really work a lot of
them audits they make a huge difference
they don't stop corruption by any means
and we all know the more accounting
that's done the more corruption you can
do if you're clever I mean it'll eat but
he said there really is an amazing
moment where provincial tax receipts and
management do get better because
everyone has to produce these co- and
send in their receipts um so and there
by the way there is this long long
reference series of references to neck
people will often say like neckers
compo- there is a real consciousness
that this begins with Necker um so by
the time we get to uh basically the end
of the Napoleonic era france starts
putting into place of the beginnings of
a modern system of public accounting
with true balance sheets um and what's
really ironic and I'm going to conclude
here what's really ironic is that the
conduct wha who have been neckers most
terrible foe because in the cold one who
he talked about the money that the crown
paid to Ottawa and he also talked about
how much the princess of the world wrote
the blood eight and thus kind of dog of
the maze oh my god so these guys already
religion they're getting huge amounts of
money that's why i hated him in fact
paid for a lot of these pamphlets
against him weirdly charles the 10th no
one looks for for these things gets this
guy the Maquis display and the Malki
display comes in and really working on
this huge tradition of corn holders and
he said that he's doing this creates one
of the first if not the first
large-scale national budget based on
double entry accounting it's not the
first national budget but it's so large
scale that in 1830 Sir John Bowring of
the British Commission that's been put
together to put together their reform
bill bowring by the way one of the most
fascinating figures of the early part of
the 19th century he supposedly speaks
200 languages will become
Hong Kong and fights for local rights in
Hong Kong he's also an expert in
accounting he goes to a Paris works with
Dudley's play and many of the accounting
reforms because he wants to see a large
scale centralized accounting reform and
how it works um and he reports these and
these amazing detailed reports back to
the Commission on accounting in England
um so essentially I mean this is a
church aptor of my book you know does it
help us understand how accounting works
one of the things that I think is
interesting here on I you know economic
historians were more of a Catamount
economic historians and I can can
explain to what extent these reforms
actually work and what they produce as
far as the you know the creation of
wealth industry these are different
questions but as far as the creation of
a language and a system and an ethos
based on accounting this moment that
Necker begins and really takes fire in
1787 has great ramifications not only on
the continent but in England which is
not usually how we sort of see the story
and the English are more advanced but as
far as the centralizing process because
they're fascinated by what the French
dude there's an incredible symbiosis of
government development towards
accountability and financial management
between these two states and
and floor time states in German states
and people are looking at and I don't
mention there's a whole mass of history
of this um but does this guarantee
financial stability and true
accountability I mean get 1832 and these
incredible reforms are there and then we
looked at what happens in our own time
they look Greek accounts I have a friend
that actually went into audit Greek
banks five years ago he told me the
situation he says beyond anyone can
imagine and when he told the Greek says
he had to get a bodyguard in London um
because seriously these guys disaster in
Greece and he was his life is threatened
so do state accounts produce
accountability will not if they're false
um one of the things what we do get in
19th century the precise moment I think
since its bicentennial of Dickens um you
know Dickens Balzac and many writers
actually Defoe before them mentioning
this problem is to none in accounting
that it gives you this assurance but of
course behind it is actually as Balzac
she use the metaphor is really this
human comedy and you know and basically
we're still living in today
but because I'm looking around the room